office door plate reads xiaofeng Zhang a
young woman with dark hair and glasses I
had a long interest in physics and
masses the hours since middle
PhD tenure track investigator and LM and
her mural research program but I was
discouraged to choose these two as my
major when I go to college and that's
because my family think that I would
have a harder time to find a job with
this major as a female based on what we
saw at that time in China
so instead I choose biology as my major
and it opened a new door for me it
actually provided the foundation for my
current research Zhang looks at human
microbiome data on a computer screen and
it also needs me to build forward of
evolution and life science
for my PhD I just choose a computation
of biology because this is a major
combine my passion in computation and my
interest in biology for long-term
observed for computer scientists if they
want to understand the mathematical data
the needle have a good understanding of
biology for biologists if they want to
speed the discovery they require the
help of computer scientists and my
background saw the bridges gaps I think
we are at the greater stages where we
can actually have the ability to turn
data into actionable items that can be
directly applied to Medical decision
making
data science and microbiome combined to
improve our health
unlim is one of the few places where I
can start my researcher program in data
science Zhang rates equations on a
whiteboard while speaking to a colleague
there is a critical master of
I am approachable from the director to
the top scientist you can just look on
the door and talk with them and they are
always willing to help
unim is a place where I can do the
research I love and enjoy and also make
a difference at the same time
NIH nlm gray and blue logo with
underlying text serving scientists and
Society